فيه سؤال ابو مها توسع صدرك
من اوسع ما يكون تسلم
عجزت القى احد مقتنع بسالفه حلال ما احد
مقتنع مهما تحاولون تقنعون الخوفتونا لما
تقولون حلال ترى منتجاتنا حلال في
السعوديه والله ما عمري فكرت فيها الا يوم
سويتوها سالت اللي حولي قاعد تبحث ابدور
انسان واحد يقول لي هل الحمله ناجحه او
فادتني او ازادت شكوكي ما في الاثر عكسي
ممتاز هل جاهزين تعترفون انها ما كانت
موفقه ولا عندك
[موسيقى]
هذا سقراط من اذاعه ثمانيه ولا عمر
الجريسي استضيف قاده التحول وقاده الاعمال
وقاده الراي وسولف معهم مع المستجدات
والمستدفات رؤيه السعوديه 2030 ضيف حلقه
اليوم هو الامير مشعل بن خالد ال سعود
الرئيس العام لشركه الرياض العالميه
للاغذيه الشركه الوكيل الحصري لعلامه
ماكدونالدز في الوسطى والشماليه والشرقيه
تجربتهم مثيره هم بداوا من التسعينات
كملوا 30 سنه في اداره هذه العلامه قطاع
المطاعم اليوم من اهم قطاعات برنامج جوده
الحياه وفي تجربه جدا عميقه في موضوع هيئه
الاعمال
وسهوله الاجراءات وقعدنا نقارن بعد ما
مرينا على قصه الشركه وقصه الحصول على
العلامه التجاريه نقارن ما بين بيئه
الاعمال قبل وبعد الرؤيه ايش اللي فرق
هوامش الربحيه انزلت في القطاع لكن
الاجراءات
والتعاون الجهه الحكوميه زاد فتحدثها هذه
ولاننا نتكلم عن علامه يعني مثيره وهذه
الحلقه ليست ترويج لاي علامه او او اي
منتج ولكن لاننا تكلمنا عنها فاضطرقنا
اكيد لموضوع الجانب الصحي
والملحوظات على
المطاعم اللي تملكها الشركه ونوعيه
الوجبات واثرها على الصحه
وسالفه حلال الحمله التسويقيه حقت حلال
اللي يمكن بالنسبه لبعض اثارت شكوقهم ولم
تساعد في تطويرهم
وكذلك تكلمنا على موضوع ليش لم يدرجوا في
السوق هل هذه من اشتراطات الشركه الام ايش
الشركه الام معاهم حاليا مين هم منافسين
هم في السوق هل تاثروا مع موجه المتاثرين
في قطاع المطاعم الفتره القصيره الماضيه
وغيرها من اسئلتكم الثمينه اترككم مع
الحوار حياك الله ابو مها شرفتو الله
يحييك ويبارك فيك وشاكلك على الدعوه
والاستضافه وسعيد جدا موجوده معك اليوم وش
قصتك مع المالديف
ههه
صار عمرك
بالنسبه لي
الماضيه
هو المكان
المفضل بالنسبه لي شخصيا عشر سنوات وكل
سنه تروح لها بشكل متكرر نفس الريزورت
صحيح يعني حاله مختلفه عن طبيعه يعني
علاقه الناس بالمالدي الصحيح معظم الناس
يقول لك الماضيه حدها اربع ايام خمس ايام
اسبوع مره في كل خمس ست سنوات ما هي وجهه
سنويه طال عمرك ولا مو بس انا وياه سنويا
ولا تقل عن 20 يوم في السنه
فهو المكان الحقيقه اللي
افصل فيه افصل فيه ذهنيا
والاهم هو الوقت اللي حقيقه اللي
عوض نفسي وعوض عائلتي ان في القضاء الوقت
معهم فيعني
من يوم ما نصبح لين ميسي وانا مع بعض لا
في روحات لا في جيات لا في اسواق في
هالجزيره
اخذ شفه منهم فالفتره فالحديث حقيقي دائما
يعني
تختلف يعني
مختلفه عن كل سفراتنا الثانيه المدن
الاخرى اللي يصير فيها نتفرق
واقعد اركز وراه مجمعهم وكذا فهذا مكان
وحيد اللي مريح بالنسبه لي جربت تروح
الاملج او الوجه او ضبا او او شمال غرب
المملكه طبعا
اذا كنا نتكلم عن الطبيعه فالطبيعه اللي
موجوده عند المملكه العربيه السعوديه يعني
بدون مجامله يمكن تعادل او تفوق طبيعه
وغيرها ولكن طبعا اللي ينقصها الخدمات صح
فهذا الحقيقه اللي يعني
يحرمنا من اننا نتمتع في الاماكن في الوقت
الحالي بسبب نقص الخدمات اللي فيها ولكن
طبعا زي ما انت عارف والجميع عارف شارع
القائمه انا على يقين من خلال سنوات
الجايه يعني
المشاريع اللي بتكون عندنا في المناطق هذه
بتغنينا عن الماضيه انا صراحه تجوز لي
سياحه الجزر بشكل عام فجرت بالي زرت سيشل
زرت المالديف يمكن مرتين
الملفت للنظر صراحه انه المالديف كطبيعه
بحريه مميزه جدا ولكن لما رحت تقوم لجرس
بحث في بحث في الوجه في منطقه نيوم ضبع
راس الشيخ حميد شارما ما شاء الله المناطق
هذيك فعلا فعلا ترتقي مناظرها الطبيعيه
انها ممكن توازي اللي كنت تشوفه في
المالديف صحيح
فهنا في عندك ميزه تنافسيه رهيبه زي ما
انتظرت ينقصها
الخدمات او البن التحتيه المؤهله وبعد
مشروع البحر الاحمر المفترض ان شاء الله
السنه هذه يعني حنتكلم عن اشهر قليله
المفترض انه
نبدا شويه نستفيد من هذه الميزه اللي
[ضحك]
اثرها في موضوع التوطين علاقتها بمرحله ما
قبل الرؤيه وما بعدها من حيث الاجراءات
والتراخيص
مفهوم جوده الحياه اللي اليوم احد برامج
تحقيق رؤيه يبغى يزيد عدد المطاعم قطاع
المطاعم في تحولات كثيره كثيره مطاعم قاعد
تخسر اليوم
الهوامش تغيرت ما بعد الرؤيه انخفضت
الهوامش ارتفعت التكاليف فقطاع حيوي وفي
صميم الرؤيه ومن عده زوايا تجربتكم تقدر
تثري هذا النقاش فاحنا قلنا نبغى نسعد
باستضافتك وناخذها رحله من البدايه وبعدين
نمر على هذه المحطات المختلفه وخلنا نبدا
يعني كذا لمحه سريعه عن الشركه الام يعني
اليوم اي احد في رياده الاعمال لازم يجيب
طاري قصه ماكدونالدز في فيلم ذا فاوندر من
اشهر الافلام اللي اي احد في هذا المجال
لازم يعني يوصي بمشاهدته
[موسيقى]
دائما ذكرها في موضوع عدد الافروع النموذج
العمل الانتشار كلها تجعل من قصتها مثيره
للمشاهدنا نعرف كذا لمحه عامه قبل ما ندخل
في تجربتكم انتم صحيح عن الشركه
يا طويل العمر شركه مكناس هي طبعا اكبر
سلسله مطاعم خدمه سريعه في العالم
تاسست عام 1955 ميلادي
اليوم في اكثر من 40 الف مطعم انتشره في
اكثر من مئه دوله حول العالم
مكناس تخدم يوميا سبعين اكثر من 70 مليون
زائر يوميا على مستوى العالم
وهي طبعا تعد من اكبر عشره اشهر واكبر 10
علامات تجاريه في العالم هي الثامن صح
حسب اضاءه التاسعه في حسب اخر الاستبيان
فهي ضمن اشهر 10 علامات في العالم
هذا فيما يخص
الشركه
يعني اتذكر انه المؤسس ما هو هو اللي قائد
النمو صح
ابتدت بشكل مختلف صحيح الطعم اول مطعم فتح
عام 1945 ميلادي وكانت اثنين اخوين اسمهم
اخوان مقداره
[موسيقى]
مجموعه فروع في كلفورنيا
وكانوا قنوعين
افتحوا لهم وكانوا يعني مقتنعين فيها
وما كان عندهم خطط التوسعها وانا كان
عندهم طموح للتوسع والى اخره
فجاء رجل اعمال ذاك الوقت اسمه
وشرى منهم الشركه
وهو اللي قاده التوسع وحولها من شركه
امريكيه الى شركه عالميه
وانطلقت عام 1955
فبعد ما بعد ما افتح اول فرع بعشر سنوات
شراها وحولها من شركه امريكيه الى شركه
عالميه وانطلق في خطتها لين وصلتها دائما
لما لما تذكر ماك ينذكر موضوع انها شركه
عقاريه وليست سلسله مطاعم هذا الشيء تحديد
ممتاز لان نظام
الفرانس عز عندهم
يشترون العقار يطورونا ويجهزونه ويبيعونه
على
او المشغل
فهذا النموذج اللي يتبعوه في امريكا وفي
الدول الكبرى في اوروبا وغيرها ولكن
الشركه الام هي اللي تشتري العقل نعم
وتجهزت وتجهزه وتاجروا على ولا تبيعه
تبيعه تبيعه على صاحب
المشغل مشغل
فهو يعني يتبرع مشغل اكثر مما هو مطور
هي شركه عقاريه بينما طبعا في
هذا النموذج اللي بداوا فيه في امريكا وفي
اوروبا وبعدين غيروا لجوا الى اسلوب اخر
منح الكامل حقوق لمناطق جغرافيه
اول كانوا بالفرع الواحد اول كان فرعينه
اي نعم افرع فتلقى شخص يملك فرع الشخص
يملك فرعين خمس فروع الى اخره فكانت يعني
تركيزهم على افراد وليس على الشركات بعدين
هنا في المنطقه صح سويت كذا طريقتهم
بالافرع والله ما عندي خبر
ممنوع نحكي عن المنافسين
نظام تشغيل تشغيلهم
بالنسبه هذا النظام السائد وعشان كذا
عندهم اليوم اربعين مطعم في اكثر من 3,500
فرانشايزن
في الشركه
لما بداوا ينتشرون الجغرافيا في انحاء
العالم طوروا سباخر اللي هو منح الوكاله
لمنطقه الجغرافيه لشخص شخص واحد بدا ما هي
عده اشخاص شخص واحد وهذه يطبق عندنا في
الخليج وفي العالم العربي
وكثير من دول اسيا
يتم منحه الامتياز لشخص واحد لمطرجيه
كامله وهذه وعام 79 غلطان
والدكم كان يدرس او قبلها كان يدرس في
امريكا وتعرف على هذه العلامه وثلاث سنوات
محاولات يقنعهم انهم يعني يدخلون السوق
السعودي صحيح فودنا هنا ندخل على قصه شركه
الرياض العالميه تحديدا وكيف حصلته على
هذا البراند والمراحل الثلاثه اللي مرت
فيها تجربتكم ممتاز
[موسيقى]
الحقيقه في بدايه في نهايه الستينات بدايه
السبعينات اللي كان الواد الله يطول في
عمره كان يدرس في امريكا وتعرف على زي ما
تفضل تعرف على علامه
اللي موجود فيها
فلما خلصت دراساته ورجعوا وكذا تقدم لهم
عام 79 ميلادي
كان اول مره يتقدم لهم عام 79 ميلادي
وطلب انها يعني
انه يكون اهل مرشحين للحصول على وكاله
فكان ردهم في ذاك الوقت
انه مرحبوا وقبلوا
الطلب ولكن قالوا ان حال في الوقت الحالي
ما عندنا اي توجه اننا نفتح في الخليج
تركيزهم كان ذاك الوقت على توسع في اوروبا
وشرق اسيا
ولكن قالوا متى ما قررنا نجي الخليج
بنتواصل معكم
فصار هو طبعا ما تركهم صار كل سنه سنتين
يتواصل معهم يتواصل معهم يتواصل معهم الين
طال عمرك عام 92 ميلادي يعني بعد ما تقدم
لهم اول مره 92 ميلادي
كلموه وقالوا اننا الان عندنا رغبه في
اننا
نتواجد في منطقه الخليج والشرق الاوسط
ويكون في علمك ان ترى في مئات متقدمين
متوقع عندنا مئات متقدمين لطلب الوكاله
فبنجي بنقعد لنا اسابيع في المملكه بنقابل
كل المتقدمين
[موسيقى]
وبنختارناه
اكثر تاهيلا
ففعلا جو
قتها في الجامعه لسه في الجامعه
جوك
عيوا ما علمونا متى بيوصلون
على الغداء من عزمكم
اللهم يوم الاجتماع بنحدد لكم يوم بنجي
نسمع معكم فيه
وهذه صار فعلا بلغ وانا قال والله انه
جايين وخلاص بنقابلكم اليوم الفلاني وجو
تقابلوا
مع الوالد ومع الفريق
اللي اللي
اعجبوا فيه انه كان محضر لهم فكان محضر
لهم دراسه عن السوق السوق المملكه وعن سوق
الخدمه المطاعم الخدمه السريعه وحجم السوق
ومن اللي موجود وكل شركه وايش عدد فروعها
مزاياها وش نقاط ضعفها
حضرنا من دراسه كامله وقتها مين اللي
موجود في السوق يمكن يعني كان يعني اشهر
العلامات اللي كانت موجوده في ذلك الوقت
اذا كنت اتكلم عن علامه المحليه كان هرفي
موجودين
كانوا موجودين
العلامات العالميه اللي كان
قبل بسنه كانوا جديدين
في السوق
كان اللي كانوا منتشرين كان كنتاكي
وهارديز كانوا منتشرين
وطبعا والباقي كله جو قبضنا بسنه بسنتين
يعني يمكن اخر علامه تجاريه عالميه تدخل
سوق السعودي
فسوينا دراسه كامله وقدمناهم
والحمد لله التوفيق من الله سبحانه وتعالى
او اخذتوا اي علامه اخرى لان هذا من شروط
طبعا طبعا
الشرط الاول طال عمرك
لا الوالد ولا عياله ولا اخوانه
يدخلون في اي شركه منافسه
عجيب حتى
[موسيقى]
الوالد عندها 35 اخ واخت
قال ما اقدر انا اشرط على 35 شخص انهم ما
يدخنون في النهايه قابلوا بالاشقه فالتزم
ان الشقاء ما يدخلون في
اي مشقه وابنائه الشقاء وابنائه ما يدخلون
نشاط برجر اي نشاط برجر منافس
ولا حتى مستثمرين
وكان عندنا في وقتها كان كان عندنا
استثمارات في شركه منافسهم عالميه عالميا
مو في السعوديه
والزموا الوالدنا انه يتخرج منها يبيعه
بالكامل
مع انها في منطقه بعيده تماما عن الشرق
الاوسط ولكن قال يعني هذا شروطهم
جدا هذا طبعا لا يحق لك بيع اي حصه من
الشركه ولا يحق لك ادخال اي مستثمرين معك
في الشركه لا يحق لنا طرح الشركه مساهمه
في شروط
يعني صعب
لا بعد حدود لدرجه
ولا عندهم مرونه في التفاوض ما عندهم
لدرجه يعني
والله قبل ما اوقع بليله يقول ما نمت
بكره حفل توقيعي يقول والله ما نمت متردد
والتبعاتها على اخرين يعني على اخرين على
اخواني على عيالي وكل شيء عليك
ولا يعني
والله الليله اني قعدت يعني استخير اوقع
ما اوقع والحمد لله انا وقع
وهذا كان 92 اول فرع
ميلادي بعدها بسنه فتحنا اول فرع سكرت
الحاره علينا
احنا السكان
طويل بشكل مرعب صحيح
بوش كواليس هذاك الفرع الاول هذا الفرع
الاول طال عمرك فتح ناه وقعنا طعمك
الوكاله عام ديسمبر 92 وفتحنا اول فرع في
ديسمبر 93 بعده بسنه
وزي ما تفضلت طبعا كان الاقبال
مهول على الفرع الاول
وحسب الاحصائيه اللي كلهم يعني زوار
امريكا هذول كلهم جمهوره امريكا
واوروبا كان موجود مقياس كان موجوده في
اوروبا كلها وفي امريكا ذاك الوقت
التجاريه يعني بس برا مثلا
في السعوديه مو بمره بس بره مثلا هو يعتبر
ند او كي اف سي يعتبر ند ولا
بس ما كان فيها ضجه مثلا او ما سوى
كل سوق تفتح فيها يكون فيها ضجه اوكي جميع
الاسواق حتى
لما افتحها في فرنسا لما افتحها في
بريطانيا في اليابان دائما وين ما تفتح
اول فرع يكون لها ضجه اوكي وهذا كان اول
فرع
توسعتم المحافظات قبل ولا انت رحت امريكا
فتح 93 انا في وقتها كنت في الجامعه اخر
اي نعم اخر سنتين تخرج 95 95 تخرجت
وتزوجت ورحت عمرك شهر العسل 30 يوم
وجدوله شارع عسل اني انتهي في واشنطن دي
سي
سبب ان ان مقدار شرطها ان السي اي او يخوض
برنامج تدريب مكثف
قبل ما انضم لشركه رياضه العالميه كان من
شروطهم اني ادرب
فاخترت اني اتدرب في واشنطن
ورحت هناك طال عمرك
مده برنامج ثلاث شهور طبعا تدريب في
المطعم ميداني تدريب ميداني في المطعم
وقالوا لي استقبال ما شاء الله حافله
تعال يوم الفلاني للفرع الفلاني الساعه
الفلانيه فرحت اول يوم وفعلا لقيت عمرك
جاي يعني وفد من من مقدار من كبار مسؤولين
هم
واستقبلوني وتحففوني ودخلوني جوا الفرع
وعرفوني على المدير الفرعي والفريق اللي
اللي بيدربوني وجلسوني وقهوني واستعرضوا
على برنامج التدريب كامل وقالوا بكره
الصباح تبدا ساعه تعال خليك عندنا سبعه
ونص الصباح
ثاني يوم صباح سبعه ونص وانا عندهم
طبعا ما كان في احد استقبالي دخلت عمرك في
امريكا وقت الدروه عندهم
فاجيتهم سبعه ونص دخلت
خليت نحل
زحمه
ادور وجهي عارفه ما لقيت احد فقعد ربعي
فقعدت يمكن عشر دقائق ربع ساعه ما ادري ما
لقيت احد المهم شفت لي مدير الفرع بعيد
صوت لي صوت لي قال لي استرح وبجيك بعد شوي
قمت فاضي
يمكن 45 دقيقه انتظر
جاني وقال لي صباح الخير ويتكلم معي بنبره
مختلفه عن اليوم اللي قبلها جاهز قلت له
جاهز قال تعال وسلمني عند واحد من
اعضاء فريقه قال هذا اللي بيكون مسؤول عن
تدريبك وراح مدير المطعم اختفى بشغله مدير
وقال لي حسب يلا نبدا الان واعطاني طال
عمرك سطل ومكنسه قال الله يكرمك في
الحمامات
فكان هذا هو المهمه
تنظيف تنظيف الله يكرمك يكرمك المشاهدين
الارضيه ومن بعدها تنظيف المواقف برا
والحدائق
الى اخره وبعدين شوي شوي دراجت على كل
المحطه داخل المطعم
والافران والى اخره
وترقى لمدير وردي مدير ثاني مدير أولي ن
تخلص بعدها شهور اصبح مدير
الحمد لله
ورجعت وهذه حقيقه كانت اهم ثلاثه شهور في
مسيرتي العمليه يعني هي اللي خلتني انجح
في قياده الشركه ليش
تفهم اللي قاعد يصير خلف الكواليس يعني
يعني من الصعب انك تقود اي نشاط اذا ما
تفهم تفاصيله واذا ما تعرف الخلفياته واذا
ما تعرف
كواليسه صعب تتخذ قرارات خاطئه اجتهادات
خاطئه فكونك تعرف وتفهم التفاصيل تعينك
على اتخاذ القرارات والسياسات اللي
تعديل النجاح
[موسيقى]
من تطور البناء الى اناقه التصميم ورفاهيه
الخدمات مع تميز الموقع حلول سكنيه مبتكره
ومستدامه مع شركه صفاء للاستثمار المزيد
في وصف الحلقه
[موسيقى]
وبعد ما رجعت بمهاء
نقدر نقول انه بشكل سريع 30 سنه مرت فيها
شركه الرياض العالميه بهذه العلامه في
السعوديه
طبعا احنا لازم نوضح انه انتم ماسكين جزء
من المملكه وفي شركه
بعدين نحكي عن المراحل الثلاثه اللي انت
توصل فيها دائما رحله
ممتاز صحيح
بالنسبه للمملكه تحديدا
[موسيقى]
كون المملكه العربيه السعوديه هي اكبر سوق
في الشرق الاوسط فكانوا حريصين
انهم ينجحون في اختيار الوكيل المناسب
اللي
بيعطي البراند حقه
في المملكه
فكانوا في الاساس يبون يقسمون المملكه الى
ثلاث مناطق الوسطى والشرقيه والغربيه
هذه كانت خطتهم في الاساس
ومنطق فيها
لو واحد من الوكلاء فشل في وكاله اخرين
يقدرون ياخذون محله بدون ما تتاثر عمل
العمليات العلامه التجاريه
فهذه ما سوى في اي دوله خليجيه ثانيه لا
لا بس السعوديه فقط السعوديه طيب ابدا بس
في السعوديه بس في السعوديه لسبب لان كانت
السعوديه هي تجربتهم الاولى في الخليج
والشرق الاوسط
فتعلموا منها
وعدلوا في السياسه في الاسواق الاخرى
في المملكه
كانت توجهوا في الاساس ترى انهم يختاروت
وكلام بعد ما
في وكيلين في المملكه
عندنا اليوم على مستوى المملكه في 371 فرع
منها 221 فرع في منطقتنا و150 فرع في
منطقه الغربيه عندنا اليوم طال عمرك
11,500 موظف على مستوى المملكه منهم 7000
عندنا و4,500 في المنطقه الغربيه نخدم
اليوم طعمك على مستوى المملكه اكثر من 200
مليون زائر سنويا الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
نقطه الوصول اليوم او واقعنا اليوم ناخذ
الرحله بشكل مجزئ على ثلاث مراحل جميل
ونبدا بتجربه الفشل في المحافظات انتم بدك
توسعون في المحافظات بناء على توصيتهم
وبعدين جابوا فيكم العيد
فرجعتوا شوي طال عمرك لما لما فتحنا الفرع
الاول
العزيه طبعا زي ما تفضلت كان الاقبال مهول
وكان خط السير سته كيلو ودار مدار في ايام
الافتتاح
وذكريا مقداره طبعا ما عنده خبره اول مره
ندخل في هالمجال فمعنى طبعا نعتمد على
خبره اهل الخبره قالوا لنا توقعوا نزول
30% عن المبيعات اللي انت قاعد تحققونا
اليوم توقعوا نزول 30% وبعد كده بتستقرون
كان رقم مهول
قلنا والله اذا كان هذه هذه المبيعات
بتستمر على مع التوسع
بتكون نتائج مبهره يعني
فوثقنا في
المعلومات
وبدينا في الانتشار يعني بعد بعد العزيزيه
بكم شهر فتحنا فرع الثاني بعد كم شهر فرع
الثالث ثلاث مدينه الرياض اول ثلاث فروع
مدينه الرياض
واحد في الملز والفرع الثالث في حي الروضه
واسف لو قاطعتك هنا بس عشان دور ماك في
هذه المرحله هل هم يجون يعطونك الصوص
موقعينك على يحطونه في خزنه يعني هذا
بالنسبه لهم هو الاسد الاهم التدريب
الموظفين وش بالضبط كان دورهم دورهم يعني
اساسي اساسي الى اليوم وهذه حقيقه الاشياء
اللي تميز عالميه انهم يعني شركاء حقيقيين
يعني
[موسيقى]
كل
كل الابتكارات كل الاختراعات كل الانظمه
كل البرامج التدريب
برامج الموارد البشريه
كل اللي البرامج التسويقيه كلها هم
يطورونها
انه دورنا اننا نختار اللي يناسب سوقنا
ونطبقه
بشكل مميز بس وشو لازم يكون فيه بالاسعار
نوعيه الوجبات ابدا ابدا طبعا الوجبات
الوجبات مثلا المنيو في في وجبات رئيسيه
يسمونها هذه لازم تكون موجوده في كل
العالم مثل
ما تلعب فيها اوكي ولكن انك تضيف منتجات
تناسب الذوق المحلي اذواق المحليه فعندنا
مثلا الماك عربي منتجات اللي طورناها هنا
في السعوديه
ومن انجح منتجات عندنا
وحصريه في السعوديه بس ما تقاف اي مكان
اخر وفي بعض الدول الخليج وهل يعطونكم
الخلطات هذه جاهزه ومصنوعه ولا يعطونكم
طريقه اعدادها لا هذه ولا هذه طعمك مقدس
ايضا من الاشياء اللي تميزها انها ما تملك
اي ما لها اي ملكيه في اساس الامدادات لا
تملك مصانع ولا تملك مزارع ولا تملك شيء
ابدا
عندهم طعم قاعده بيانات قاعده موردين
معتمدين
وكلنا ندخل على القاعده هذه
للمرونه وكامل الحريه اني اختار اي مورد
معتمد فمثلا
اللحوم عندك مئات مصانع حول العالم لان
معتمده فانا عندي مرونه اني اروح اختار اي
من هالمصانع
واستورد منها
فالشرط الوحيد بس اني اتعامل مع موردين
معتمدين
عندنا الحمد لله في السعوديه
لما بدينا طال عمرك عام لما فتحنا عام 93
كان مئه في المئه من منتجاتنا مستورده مئه
في الميه اليوم الحمد لله خمسين في المئه
من منتجاتنا محليه داخل السعوديه خمسين
بالمئه من اهمها من اهم الخبز
الاجبان الالبان الخضروات
كلها
القرطاسيات
معظم اكثر من نصف منتجاتنا محليه اليوم
الزبده من برا اللحوم والدجاج الدجاج
الدجاجه صحيح اللحوم والبطاطس الاستراليا
اللحوم
حاليا ولكن تتغير زي ما قلت لك انا عندي
قائمه
اشوف الافضل من ناحيه الاقرب مسافه اقرب
مسافه
الافضل سعرا الافضل جوده وهل ممكن يكون
فرع من من مورد وفرع من مورد اخر ممكن
ممكن لانه قبل التصوير قاعد اسال زملاء
اسف على الاستيراد بس اسال الزملاء
المصورين اقول لهم مش بقابل رئيس ماك وش
بتقول وش بتسالونه فواحد يقول ليش في فرق
في الطعم
وهذه ملفته يعني غنيت انه الجوده حتحافظ
على الطعم في كل مكان نعم افهم انها تكون
بين الغربيه والوسطى بحكم اداره تشغيليه
مختلفه حتى فرع السويدي يفرق عن الفرع
يحطين يفترون يقول هذه تجربته
هل هذه لها علاقه بالموردين ولا لا علاقه
بالتشغيل
اذا اذا كان في فرق في الطعام فيكون بسبب
اسباب تشغيليه وليس لكن المصدر واحد اوكي
مصدر واحد
[موسيقى]
يتدربون
للافتتاح وجزء من خبره ماك انه قالوا لكم
ترى انتم اموركم طيبه في المبيعات تنزل
بعد 30% 30%
فتوسعوا توسعوا وش الغلطه اللي صارت
الغلطه اللي صارت ولكن في وقتها كانت
مؤلمه تجربه مؤلمه ولكن
فافتحنا اول الفرع الرابع بتاعنا في
الشرقيه ايضا لمفتاح في الشرقيه كان في
شبه يعني
كان في قبال كبير زي ما صار في الرياض
بعدين طال عمرك
بدينا
نتوسع فتحنا فرعين في القصيم وفرع في
الاحساء في نفس الوقت
وهنا بدات مراره التجربه
لما فتحنا في القصيم وفتحنا في الاحساء ما
كان فيه طوابير
كان يعني كان كاتف افتتاحات محبطه
واستمر طبعا
الاقبال شبه معدوم في الفروع هذه ليش
جميل صدمه
[موسيقى]
فطبعا لا نعرف ليه ولا مكناس يعرفون ليه
شكلنا لجنه وبين مقص
ورحنا زرنا
المناطق هذه وانا كنت معهم ميدانيه مقابل
الناس في الشارع
نسالهم تعرفونها مطعم ولا ما تعرفونه
ولا ما جربتو ولا ما جربتوه ليش ليش ما
تجربونا الى اخره كان يعني خلاصه الدراسه
هذه كانت عده الاسباب اول شيء ان كان كان
في رفض لها كونها علامه امريكيه
رقم اثنين كانوا يشوفون فخامه المبنى
فيعتقدون انه مطعم غالي
فخامه مطعم كان يعطي انطباع سيء عن عن
العلامه
هذه كانت
ابرز سببين
فبناء عليها
حطينا خطه اننا نعالج نصحح هالمفاهيم
الخاطئه
امريكيه المقدار شركه عالميه شركه مساهمه
يملكونها ملايين الناس اشخاص من حول
العالم العرب والمسلمين انا املك فيها الى
مستويات فسوينا حملات كبيره على الموضوع
هذا وين مقداس في السعوديه هي شركه سعوديه
اللي يملكونها السعوديين مئه في المئه في
اي حصه في المطاعم في السعوديه
الى اخره فبدينا نسوي حملات تثقيفيه
توعويه
بكثافه الاسعار ايضا نسوي حملات تسويقيه
نوضح حقيقه اسعارنا اللي يميز عالميا وفي
السعوديه المقدار تقدم اجود منتجات باقل
الاسعار اقل الاسعار متفقين عليها اجود
المنتجات
هذا النجاح في العام كله
ولكن
الطوابير اللي كانت موجوده في العزيه هذه
الناس اللي يعرفون مقدامز من خلال سفرهم
ولكن لما رحنا مناطق الثانيه ما يعرفون
العلامه فاخذت اخذت سنين اخذت سنين من من
الصبر والجهد ويمكن تحديدا هذيك الفتره
العشر سنوات الاولى التسعينات بدايه ال
2000 كان دائما اي حدث
قومي او او عربي او دائما اول يعني مرمى
للهجوم هو ماكدونالدز صحيح مقاطعه يعني
الانتفاضه في فلسطين قاطعه
يعني اجتياح اسرائيلي لمستوطنات قاطعوا
فكيف كنتوا تتعاملون مع فكره انه انتم
كيان دائما
اول خط هجوم
لاي انتفاضه اسلاميه او عربيه ممتاز قبل
ما جابك على سواء طال عمرك كلامك 100%
صحيح مقداموس دائما
هدف سهل
بحكم انها علامه مشهوره وعلامه معروفه
فدائما وعلامه قدام عيون الجميع اي شارع
تمشي فيه بتبقى مقناص بعكس بعض العلامات
الاخرى اللي قد تكون علامات مشهوره ولكن
يعني ما هي قدام عينك
لهذا السبب مقدارز كانت دائما يعني
متهمه باي شيء يصير
يعني جزاء لا يتجزا من حياتنا اليوميه
حملات مقاطعه حملات المقاطعه المقاطعه
ولكن الاشاعات الى يومك اشاعات يعني
ما يمر شهر شهرين الا تطلع اشاعه معينه
صارت اتذكر واحد من اقاربي كان يعني يجزم
لانه هو يعني شوهد موظف فلبيني في
ماكدونالدز يطلع دم من جسمه في ايد ويعبي
فيه على بالكاتشب
وحنا صغيرين نصدقها صحيح
هذا يعني منتج خطير على صحتنا وعلى
عقيدتنا وعلى ثقافتنا صحيح اي نعم صحيح
كيف تتعاملون طيب مع تحدي زي كذا تعاملنا
مع طال عمرك
الاولى والثانيه يمكن نقسم تجربتنا
السنه هذه
نهايه ديسمبر 20 23 سنه ان شاء الله
نقسم مطعمك العاشر سنوات الاولى نسميها
الحقيقه الثانيه ان المقدار
في السعوديه شركه سعوديه مكناس في فرنسا
فرنسيه مكناس في الصين صينيه من خلال اصلا
شعار انها شركه عالميه بوجه محلي
فمكنات بكل سوق محليه تتكيف مع ثقافات
وعادات وتقاليد
السوق اللي هي فيها
حملات مستمره طعمك اول عشر سنوات حملات
مستمره على التثقيفيه على هالحقائق هذه
الجوده المنتجات زي ما تفضلت يعني
اتهمنا بمليون اتهام خاطئه
المثال اعطيته في امثله كثيره يقول لك انه
يدخلون البقاره كامله في المكينه وتطحنها
وتطلع
زين بقره
يعني روايات اخرى اصلا مبلحمة مو بلحم تم
اجره اختبارات يعني
موضوع اصل هذه المواد يعني في كثير سووا
اختبارات ووثقوها بالفيديو يوتيوب اطباء
وقالوا شوفوا يا جماعه الخير الاكل ما
يتعفن تعفن اربع اربع اسابيع خمسه اسابيع
ما المسوا شيء طعمه بالنسبه لبعض الناس
يقولون ما هو طبيعي فودنا نعرف اصل وحقيقه
لحمكم ودجاج ممتاز
يعني
صعب ولكن انا اقول لشيء اللي ابري ذمتي
قدام رب العالمين فيه
المنتجات يتقدمها مقداموس هي اجود انواع
المنتجات اللي تقدم ليس بس في القطاع
المطاعم الخدمه السريعه مقارنه
مقارنه بالمنتجات اللي ناكلها في بيوته
هذا شيء انا يعني
اتحمل مسؤوليتها قدام رب العالمين طيب من
مواقع من واقع اطلاعي انا اشوف نوعيه
اللحم اللي تقدم مقداد صقارنها بنوعيه
اللحم تقدم في بيتي اشوف نوعيه البطاطس من
نوعيه زين
فالمنتجات تقدمها اجود من اللي تقدم في
طريقه لاثبات ذلك يعني هذه وجهه نظر ما هي
وجهه نظر هذه حقيقه كيف كيف وايش
المستندات او الاسس اللي بنيت عليها هذه
الحقيقه انا كمشاهد من برا كيف اتاكد كيف
اتاكد عمرك يعني عندك اول شيء اول شيء طال
عمرك عندك
على الموقع الالكتروني حقنا موجود فيها كل
منتج مكونات منتج وقيمه الغذائيه لكل منتج
موجوده
رقم اثنين عندنا عندنا الشهادات عندنا طال
عمرك
بعطيك مثال اللحم اللحم طبعا اللحم لحم
بقري صافي ميه في الميه ما في اي اضافات
ولا في اي
مواد حافظه الى اخره
نجري عليها اكثر من خمسين اختبار من
المزرعه الى المستهلك 50 اختبار
معداتنا يوميا ثلاث اربع مرات يتم
كشف عليها تاكد من سلامه
عمرك يعني
مطعم اي مطعم يقدم اكل
سمعته كلها متعلقه فالاكل اللي هو قدمه صح
ولا لا
يقدر لا والله يقدر منتجك كان سيء
لو الله لا يقدر
منتجك كان غير صحي لول الله يقدمه سبب اي
حالات تسمم او العلاقه قدر الله وامراض
ولا وفيات وش بيصير انت
وفي شركات صارت لها صار لها شيء مرتفع
التجارب كان في شركه امريكيه مشهوره في
السبعينات والثمانينات امريكا
مطعم خدمه سريعه همبرجر الى اخره افلست
الشركه ليه صار عندهم حالات تسمم على
مستوى كبير يعني مئات الاشخاص تسمموا وصار
اعتقد اعتقد صارت في حالات وفيات الاخره
عدم التعفن وشالفه سرعه الاعداد يعني لو
انه فريش ما يتجهز بهالسرعه الكثيرين شلون
تعلق على عدم تعفن يا طويل العمر ببساطه
ببساطه
مثبت علميا اللي يسبب التعفن طال عمرك هو
الرطوبه الرطوبه ودرجه حراره يعني
فاي اكل اي اكل همبرجر مقداومز ولا لا لو
اخذتها همبرجر من اي مطعم اخر وحطيته في
مكان ما في رطوبه وفي درجه ودرجه بروده
بارده ما يتعفن لو يقعد مئه سنه
التجربه اللي طبقت على مقدار وطبقتها على
اي همبرجر من السوبر ماركت ولا في بيتك
ولا من اي مطعم نفس الشيء بيكون نفس نتيجه
ولكن ما احد يجرب على
المصادر الاخرى دعم التركيز على مقداس
بحكم انها هي العلامه الاشهر فهي سبب
الظروف المناخيه اللي تم التجربه فيها ومن
خلال سوت يعني مقدار
سوتيه بنفسها
عمدت مختبرات مختصه مستقله
ان تسوي نفس الاختبارات وسوى الاختبارات
وثابت نفس النتيجه انه جابوا لحوم من
السوبر ماركت وسووا نفس الظروف وما تعفنت
يعني
يخليه يحافظ على كل ما ينشف يحافظ على
الموادي الاخره
فيجيك مثلا بطاطس والدجاج الدجاج الدجاج
مطبوخ مطبوخ في المصنع
صالح للاستخدام
فنقليه القليه الاخيره
هو مطبوخ مجمد
واللهم انا نحطه نقليه الاخيره
فهذا هذا هذا فهي طريقه الاعداد والتحضير
على مستوى مصانع اللي يتمكننا مننا في
المطعم
نجهز بشكل وفي تجربه يعني عشان نقفل فيها
موضوع المرحله التعريفيه هذه في موضوع
الشخص اللي جرب في امريكا انه ياكل 30 يوم
من معك يمكن سمعت عن التجربه اللي جاء له
يعني اكتئاب ويعني مضاعفات صحيه
وكان يعني يشير الى انه هذا اثر
تعليقي عليه يا طويل العمر اي شيء تفرط
فيه بضرك اي شيء تفرض فيه الرز لو فرطنا
فيه ذبحنا
اللحم لو فرطنا فيه ذبحنا يعني انك ما
يعني انك تقعد 30 يوم تاكل منتج واحد ثلاث
مرات في اليوم اكيد نبي يضرك
هل انت تسمح في لاولادك في بيتك يوميا
يوميا يوميا اقسم بالله ما شاء الله واحد
ياكل معك
المفاهيم الخاطئه يعني المفهوم خاطئ اللي
ياكل المقدار يوميا
يعني كل الصوره الذهنيه والمعرفه
المجتمعيه بانه هذا المطعم هو اللي قاعد
يسبب سمنه وقاعد يسبب مرتفع وش يسبب
السمنه سعرات حراريه حلو صح ولا لا فانت
يا طويل العمر
جسمك يتطلب السعرات حراريه معينه في اليوم
الواحد اذا تجاوزت السعرات الحراريه بتسمع
واذا استهلكت اقل من السعرات الحراريه
بتنحف صح ولا لا ايا كان لك سواء كان
مقدامز ولا كان رز ولا كان مكرونه اللي
يكون
فمهم صحيح انه والله ذبات المكناس
اذا باكل من مطعم باء
مو صحيح هو على كم تستهلك من سعرات حراريه
وسعرات حراريه موجوده عند زي ما قلت لك
موجوده في الموقع الالكتروني عندنا تشوف
كل وجبه وجباتنا طال عمرك
في اعمارنا نحتاج الى الفين سعره حراريه
في اليوم تقريبا فلما تاكل 700 سعره
حراريه
فهذا كانت اول عشر سنوات اللي اللي فيها
جهدكم مركز على اني اعرف الناس بالمنتج
تسمح لي بس
انت الله يجزاك خير
التجارب السيئه ولكن في تجارب كثير ناجحه
يا ريت تسمم قصه تسمم ولا مو هنا ولا لا
ناجحه طبعا على السمنه على السمنه
فيه الاف
التجارب المنشوره على اليوتيوب وعلى
تواصلت اجتماعي ناس يسوون رجيم على وجبات
مكتوبه اجي اي نعم
الزين موجود
انا انا عندي زملاء من موظفين في الشركه
يعني يسوون رجيم بطعمك في واحد من الزملاء
نحف 14 كيلو 14 كيلو ما ياكل الاقدونس
يعني وجبه فيهم وجبه واحده بس بدون
البطاطس وبدون الكورونا كامله كامله بكلش
زين 700 700 سعره حراريه جسمك يحتاجها
فيها سعرها
لما تعكس
غير صحي انك تاكل
في الصبح شيخ خفيف
وخذ لك وجبه واحده في اليوم
سعره حراريه ولا سعره حراريه بتنح
ف في مليان تجارب من
بس تخيل انه يعني لو في لو في غذائين
حيقولوا له اوكي عدد السعرات صحيح انه
قليل لكن المدخلات ما هي صحيه المدخلات ما
هي مو صحيح
يعني
الجبن المدخلات خس طماطم
لا لا
في حياتنا
ولكن على بطاطس مثلا
نوعيه الزيت
نوعيه نوعيه الزيت عنصر مهم جدا وانه طال
عمرك كنا سباقين
غيرنا زيوتنا من زمان من اكثر من عشر
سنوات غيرنا زيوتنا من
كنا نستخدم زياده زيت الدر اول غيرناه طال
عمرك زيت دوار الشمس والزيت دوار الشمس
هذا من اكثر الزيوت الصحيه
لا في زيوت مشبعه في زيوتنا غير مشبعه
فيعني نحرص على نكون كل المنتجات نستخدمها
تكون اجود انواع المنتجات تكون صحيه
علينا يعني قبل السلطات المحليه ولا لا
هذه مبادرات مكناز عالميا تتخذها من واقع
مسؤوليتها
وفعليا فعليا هذا اخر سؤال بعدين
وش تفسيرك لعدم اقتناع المجتمع يعني حتى
اللي ياكلون معك هما مستمتعين فيه بس
يعرفونه ما بصحي يعرفون انه مضر يعني واحد
من اخواني عاشق ولازم ياكل يعني بشكل شبه
يومي بس هو يعرف انه مضر ويعرف انه صحي هو
كذا مقتنع انت بتصلح مفهوم الخلطه هذا
اليوم ليش هذه الصوره الذهنيه عند كل
الناس
لان طال عمرك زي ما قلت لكم
[موسيقى]
هي العلامه من اكبر علامات التجاريه
العالميه وكونها هي الرائده في في قطاع
مطاعم خدمه سريعه في العالم يعني
في ضريبه تدفعها جراح النجاح
لو واحد تكلم عن مطعم مطعم اخر ما يلفت
انتباهه او ما يشد المشاهد بس لما تشوف
مقدار تشد
فكثير من المغرضين وكثير من
[موسيقى]
بدينا نشوف تحول كبير في ادائنا تحول
ايجابي في ادانا
الفروع اللي ذكرتك اياها اللي بدينا نشوف
يعني منعطف حاد في ما قفلتوها بس حاولناها
اوكي بتقولي وش خلقك الله
بدينا نشوف تحول كبير يعني بعد مرور عشر
سنوات
من 2003 من 2003 بدينا نشوف تحول كبير في
ادائنا في مبيعاتنا بدينا بدينا نحقق
ارباح
بدات تكبر حصتنا وحصتنا السوقيه وصلت
واتوقع 130 فرع على نهايتها
عشر سنوات
كنا نفتح له ثلاث اربع فروع في السنه بس
مع نهايتها 2012 نهايه العشر سنوات 2003
ايه
2003 الله الله
2012 وهذه وصلت 130 فرع
نهايه مع نهايه مرحله فهذه وصلتوا 130
بدينا ننتشر فيها اوكي عشان بدينا نشوف
تحسن مع بدايتها توصيف حلو تقول لي انه
هذه اللي الناس ياكلون صحيح الاكثر
استخدام لكن ليس العالم المفضله
طال عمرك
زي ما بدانا شفت حسن
وكل سنه استنى اشوف قفزات في الاداء سنه
عن سنه ولكن اصبحنا لكر استخدام ولكن ليس
العلامه المفضله يعني الاكثر استخدام ليه
وهذا عشان كده نسمي المرحله التكتيكيه لان
انتشرت فروعنا صار الفرع قريب فبدا ما
اروح اسوق عشر دقايق ربع ساعه في فرع
مكناس قريب من عندي
السعر السعر السعر السعر
السرعه
للاسباب العمليه
ولكن ليس العلم مفضله للاسباب اللي ذكرنا
اتكلمنا عنها يعني في علامات استفهام
كثيره على العلامه التجاريه وبعدها الحين
عشر سنوات الثالثه والعشر سنوات الثالثه
هاي طال عمرك هذه
نسميها مرحله الولاء
اللي هي مقدارز هي الاكثر استعمالا او
استخداما
والاكثر ولاءا
من قبل عملائنا
باختصار اصبحنا جزء لا يتجزا من حياه
عملائنا اليوميه
واصبحنا يعني
جزء من
تواجد في عندهم وهذه المرحله الحقيقه اللي
يعني كنا نبغى نسعى نوصل وصلت 220 فرع
المرحله الثالثه
220 وفي المنطقه الغربيه عندك 371 فرع على
مستوى المملكه السنه هذه يا طويل العمر
عند الخط طموح ان شاء الله بنفتح 45 فرع
زين على مستوى المملكه 45 فرع عنا 30
والمطرقه غربيه بتحويل 15 فبنفتح 45 فرع
فان شاء الله مع نهايه السنه هذه
عدد فروعنا بتوصل الى اكثر من 415 فرع ان
شاء الله مع نهايه السنه على مستوى
المملكه وبالتالي بنصبح اكبر سلسله مطاعم
خدمه سريعه في المملكه مع نهايه السنه هذه
ان شاء الله
في فرع فخطوه ان شاء الله مع نهايه السنه
هذه ان شاء الله
نتجاوزها يعني انتو شاهدتوا او شهدتوا
المرحله التحول اللي اللي عاشتها السعوديه
مع الرؤيه وفيها عده متغيرات تلامسكم سواء
في تسهيل اجراءات الاستثمار سواء في
التركيز على موضوع التوطين سواء في موضوع
الاهتمام بالمحتوى المحلي لو نتكلم على
تقريبا تقريبا عندكم 130 فرع قبل الرؤيه
وعندكم 110 فرع بعد الرؤيه تقريبا هذه
الحسبه
وش اللي فرق في نشاطكم
سلبا او ايجابا بعد اطلاق الرؤيه ممتاز
سلبا ما في شي سلبا ايجابا في امثله كثيره
الاجابه
شوي ان السنه هذه نفتح 45 فرع على المملكه
وهذه اول سنه في 30 سنه الماضيه نفتح هذا
العدد الكبير من الفروع سنوات يعني ثلاثين
سنه راحت كان معدل 15 فرع اتكلم عن انه
المنطقه الغربيه
متسمعين نفتح 15 في السنه هذه في افضل
الاحوال افضل الاحوال 15 20 15 20 هذا في
افضل الاحوال السنه هذه بنفتح ضعف العدد
هذا
وهذا يعكس مدى ثقتنا كان مستثمرين في
حكومتنا وفي اقتصادنا وفي سوقنا
فاعتقل هذا الجواب طبعا يمكن يعني لما
تشوف المستثمرين قاعدين
يتوسعون وقاعدين وبخير
لا لا
طبعا
كل شيء تحسن كل شيء تحسن كل شيء يتحسن
وقاعد حسن ما بعد وصلنا في في مجالات
كثيره
ما بعد وصلنا للنساله ولكن الاهم
بالنسبه لي انا طال عمرك كمستثمر اني احس
واللي اول مره احس ان صوتي مسموع
احس ان رايي ياخذ
احس ما تاخذ رايكم وش في رايكم اعطيك
يوميا تاخذ ارائنا ان الان طال عمرك يعني
اليوم اليوم
يعني في
لجان مشتركه بين القطاع الخاص والقطاع
العام في جميع الوزارات بدون استثناء
[موسيقى]
هذا النهج اللي طال عمرك اللي اللي نتج عن
اعلان الرؤيه وبرنامج يتحول الوطني
زي ما انت عارف يعني
[موسيقى]
القياده دائما هي اللي ترسم المسار
يعني قيادتنا مثلا
من ركائز برنامج تحول الوطني اشراك القطاع
الخاص في صناعه القرار ان القطاع الخاص
يكون
مساهم كبير في تحقيق البرنامج
فالسياسه وضعت واعلن عنها والحكومه ماشيه
في السياسه هذه
من تجربتي انا الشخصيه خلال ثلاثين سنه
راحت مع مع الحكومه
كان قبل الرؤيه والبرنامج البرنامج تحول
الوطني كان دائما ينظر على القطاع الخاص
على انه
دائما ونعامل على هذا اساس
رحنا اشتكينا وبخنا اذا طالبنا اتهمنا
بالجشع
فدائما كان في نظره دينيه لقطاع خاص
نظره عن القطاع الخاص حمل وعبا
هذا قبل
بعد
اعلان الرؤيه او البرنامج
كافي مرحله لمده حوالي سنتين يعني 2015
الى 2017
كان في شراكه شكليه
يعني في كثير من المسؤولين يمكن ما كانوا
مقتنعين او ما كانوا مهيئين نفسيا انهم
يعني فعلا يمارسون
المطلوب فكان في شراكه فعليه وكانت معاناه
عشان يظهرون انها شراكه ولكن في الواقع ما
شراكه نقول شيء ويصير شيء اخر ورشه عمل
نقعد ورشه عمل
المحضر الاجتماع محضر قبل الورشه العمل
فنطالب انه نوقع المحضر الاجتماعي وما في
اي شيء من اللي نوقش في ورشه العمل
فهذه صارت
المده سنتين بعدين
دخلنا في مرحله الشراكه الفعليه من 2018
الى اليوم مرحله شراكه فعليه زي ما قلت لك
صوتنا مسموع ارانا يؤخذ فيها يطلب مننا
يطلب مننا باستمرار اننا نساعد في طرح
تشريعات محدده قبل ما تطلع اي تشريعات
تخصنا او تمسنا تعرض علينا تاخذ مرئياتنا
فيها
يعني لاول مره يقال لنا جيبوا لنا تجارب
من دول اخرى اعطوني اياها يعني اعطونا
مرئياتكم نقعد مع بعض ورش عمل
مشتركه بين القطاع الخاص والقطاع العام
لصيغ الانظمه لصيغ القوانين هذه حقيقه هذه
انا اشهدها بنفسي صايره وهذه كلها اشياء
ايجابيه لكن في اخرين يشوفون من السلبيات
موضوع الهوامش يعني في عندي ارقام انه هون
مش القطاع صحيح نزلت جده بعد الرؤيه جده
فهذا
نجمتها نزلت
بعد نجاحه كورونا بعد بعد جائحه كورونا
طبعا طب قبل لها موضوع التوطين موضوع
يعني رسوم البلديه هذي كلها ارتفعت ولا لا
الوافدين ارتفعت هذه كلها ارتفعت فاثرت
على الهواش صحيح
يعني كم هامش القطاع عندكم
ما بين شركه وشركه ولكن انا اقول لك يعني
بالنسبه لنا اهم شيء الربح عندنا اقل من
10% اقل من عشره في المئه
يعني
كان كان كان عشره في المئه
قبل كورونا الان نزل نزل نزل بشكل كبير
الان يعني يمكن بحدود 5% نزل نصف تقريبا
يعني تكاليف المواد الغذائيه ارتفعت بشكل
مهول 200% 300 ارتفعت علينا فهذه الحقيقه
اللي اثرت على الهواء اللي خلفت
الفتره الحاليه
ولكن ان الرسوم الحكوميه اثرت
اثرت يا طويل العمر يعني اذا كان اذا كان
مبيعاتك في النمو
فزياده التكاليف زياده في المبيعات تغطي
زياده في التكاليف يعني وهذا كنا اثرت
عليكم ما اثرت عندك للامانه ما اثرت عليها
بشكل كبير اثرت لكن مو بشكل كبير وموضوع
الرقابه البلديه يعني اغلب اصحاب المطاعم
عندهم تحدي مع اجازه مع طريقه الغرامات
صحيح انا كاني فهمتوا انتم عندكم مخصص
للموضوع صحيح كان عندنا مخصص كان كان عنده
مخصص كنا نعتبرها مصاريف اداريه هذه ثابته
ثابته ثابته مدفوعه مدفوعه لان يجيكم
مراقب البلديه غير مؤهل غير غير ملم يدخل
طعمه من راسي
يخبطك ثلاث اربع مخالفات بخمسه عشر الف
بعشرين الف ريال ويطلع ولا فقد حاج فيها
يعني
نقطه معاناه بالنسبه لنا
ميزانيه سنويه نعتبرها مصاريف اداريه
ولا نشغلنا في انفسنا فيها عشان لا حول
ولا قوه
للاسف طيب هل حكيتوا على هذا الجانب و
تحددت تعدلت تعدلت وش اللي فرق فرق يا
طويل العمر الان
[موسيقى]
يعني وزاره شؤون البلديه للامانه يعني
اذكر كم وزاره الحقيقه اللي وزارات اللي
يعني
تغيرت معنا 180 درجه وزاره شؤون البلديه
والقرويه وزاره الموارد البشريه
وزاره التجاره وزاره الاقتصاد هذا بالنسبه
لي انا
كقطاع هذه الاربعه وزارات اللي الحقيقه
اشتغل معها بشكل يومي يعني
قراراتهم لها التاثير مباشر علي
كل اربع وزارات اللي ذكرتها بدون استثناء
بدون استثناء يشتغلون بنفس الروح والمنطق
اللي يتفضل فيه اللي يروح الشراكه ورش
عامل مشتركه يسمعونه ياخذون يطرحون علينا
المسودات نعطي ملاحظات اذا اذا عندنا
ملاحظات عليها اذا عندنا منطق مقنعه
يقتنعون ويعدلون اذا عاد ما عندنا مقنع من
حقهم انهم يتمسكون
تجربه صراحه فريده او او مميزه خلني اقول
في موضوع التوطين يعني انا اتذكر اول ما
بدات موجه توطين المطاعم اللغه العامه هي
لغه تدمر واعتراض صحيح اذكر الامير ماجد
يعني كصديق جامعه كان حديث مختلف في ناحيه
انه خلاص الموضوع صار ما هو ما في فائده
من مناقشته كيف تكيف معاه فصار فيه المسار
صار فيه انتظار اول من بدا الموضوع 5,600
ريال او 65000 ريال وفي مسار مهني توصل
مدير فرع ما يعرف ايش كان في حراك وجهود
اثمرت اليوم اظن في فوق الاربع سعودي في
لو كذا بشكل سريع عن هذه التجربه واهم
دروسها ممتاز بس انا ما بدي بشكل سريع
عشان هذا من اهم مواضيع خذ راحتك اللي ودي
اليوم الحقيقه تجربتنا في التوطين اعتقد
هذه من انجح تجارب مقداروس خلال 30 سنه
اللي راحت في التوطين واللي اعتقد ان
الكثير ممكن يستفيد منها من تجربتنا يا
طويل العمر اول شيء تجربتنا ما بدات
في العشر سنوات اللي راحت او 15 سنه اللي
راحت تجربتها بدات من 30 سنه من اول يوم
من اول يوم فتحنا مقداموس بدينا في
التوطين
ليه لان
سياسه مقياس عالميه زي ما قلت لك شركه
عالميه بوجه محلي قال يعني
علمونا ان
كمقد
زي ما تسعون المبيعات والارباح والى اخره
عليكم مسؤوليات لازم تتبنونها من اول يوم
المسؤوليه الاولى تطوير وتنميه القطاع
القطاع المطاعم خدمه السريعه هذه بحكم
المقدار هي الشركه الرائده والاولى في
العالم فمن مسؤوليتنا اننا ننهض بالقطاع
كامل
ثانيا دعم الاقتصاد المحلي يعني دعم
الاقتصاد المحلي من خلال توطين
المنتجات من خلال الانفاقات الراسماليه من
خلال الرسوم اللي ندفعها
للدوله سواء كانت على شكل رسوم كهرباء
رسوم جمارك والى اخره
دعم دعم دعم دعم الاقتصاد دعم المقاولين
الموردين الى اخره
وثال
دعم الاعمال الانسانيه فهذه ثلاث محاور
رئيسيه
اللي موجوده والتوطين والتوطين
فمن اول يوم مقدماغ قالوا ركزوا على انكم
توطنون ابناء وبناتكم في مطاعم كدا
فمن هذا المطلق بدينا طبعا كان الاقبال
صفر صفر يعني سوينا اعلانات في الجرائد
كالايام كذا وظائف كذا
فسوينا طالما شكلنا لجنه
من الاداره العليا وانا شخصيا راستها نبغى
نعرف ليه ليش ما في قبال وش تحديات بدينا
طعمك اسوي استبيانات ونسوي دراسات
ومقابلات نبغى نفهم ليه
الاجازات الاجانب كنا نعطيهم يوم في
الاسبوع يقول انا احتاج يومين في الاسبوع
فكان فيه تكسير كبير من القطاع الخاص في
مراعاه
احتياجات
السعودي مقارنه بالاجنبي يعني من مجحف اني
اقارن المواطن في
الاجنبي لسبب واحد الاجنبي جاي ما عنده
الا هدف واحد انه يشتغل ويترزق ويجمع فلوس
ويحولها لا يخلص بضيء عقده ويرجع لاهلها
السعودي عند حياه اجتماعيه عنده اسريه
عنده لابد ان تاخذ الاعتبار
فكان قرارنا انه لازم نكون مرنين بحيث
اننا نستخطبهم فكلا النقاط هذه عالجناها
حطينا يومين في الاسبوع حطينا سلم رواتب
للسعوديين احنا زي ما تفضلت اول ما بدينا
ذيك الايام كان
الاجانب كان العامل نجم كانت 1000 والف
1,200 السعوديه كانت 3000 ريال
بعدين رفعناها الى 45 وبعدين رفعنا الى
في اجازه في الاسبوع
اختيار موقع العمل هو اللي اختار موقع
عمله وين الفرع تبغى تشتغل فيه علمني
نحطه هناك وناخذ من الاجانب نحطهم في
الفرع الاخر نوزعهم
الورديات
الصباح خلوا يشتغل ورديات الصباح عندي
عندي عماله جانب ما تفرق معهم يشتغل الصبح
تشتغل قاعد في السكن يعني ما تفرق معاه
يعني فكر المرونه
حقيقه كان القطاع الخاص
يعني كان
متشطب فيها
فهذا اللي خلانا ننطلق ونكون سباقين وننجح
فيه تجربه كم وصلت اليوم اليوم عندنا طال
عمرك
عندي 4000
موظف من اصل خمسه
وعندنا خطط اننا نستمر في زياده النسب هذه
سنويه الخطط هذه
متفق عليها مع وزاره البشريه وهذه من
الامثله الحقيقه اللي يعني اشيل فيها على
وزاره الموارد البشريه احد مطالبنا كانت
دائما الفتاه الماضيه
اعطونا خطط
جهه الحكوميه علمونا وين رايحين علمونا وش
القرارات بتطلع بعد سنه بعد سنتين ترى
القطاع الخاص مرن قطاع خاص مرن بس ساعدوه
يخطط ساعدوا يخطط
يعني
يجون مثلا اعطيك من الامثله وزاره مواد
البشريه في
مرحله ما قبل ما قبل الرؤيه
في يوم وليله فاجئونا بقرار تعطيني
المولات بنسبه 100% واعطونا ست شهور بعد
ست شهور كل المولات بتكون موطنه بالكامل
100%
انا اقدر اوطن
زي ما انت عارف المطاعم عندك طال عمرك
طاقم خدمه الى
مدير الفرع عندك مستويات اداريه مختلفه
طاقم خدمه ما هي مشكله اقدر اوطن طاقم
خدمه خلال اسبوعين يتمكن من شغله يعني
ولكن لما تروح مدير ثاني مدير اول مدير
فرع هذول يحتاجون الى سنين من التدريب
لان اداره الفرع ما هي سهله ما هي بس طبخ
عندك طعم اداره موظفين عندك اداره ماليه
عندك اداره السلام الغذائيه اهم السلام
الغذائيه لازم يكون ملم
فلازم يكون متمكن متدرب ويحتاج الى حذف
مقداره مقدار صحته عند برنامج التدريب
سنتين لمدير الفرع اقل شيء
تقول لي بعد بعد ست شهور لازم يكون مدير
فرع سعودي ولازم المدير الثاني سعودي
والمدير الاول سعودي
ما يمكن
فطرت موعد مع الوزير في ذاك الوقت ورحت
وقابلته
الحقيقه يعني كان من اسوا اجتماعات اللي
مرت علي
شرحته
بالنسبه طاقم خدمه ما عندي مشكله
بالكامل بس موديل المطاعم احتاج الى سنتين
عطني انا ما اعترض ماني معترض بس اعطني
وحده
انا من خبرتي ان الموضوع اسبوعين ثلاث
اسابيع يكونون جاهزين
واذا ما قدرتوا واذا ما قدرتوا ترى الفلاش
مو بعيد اوف نعم
ترى ناس ترى هذه هذه الدوره دوره اقتصاديه
ناس تفلس وناس تبدا وكذا
وصار يعني صار في احتلال بيني وبينه في
الاستماع ما طلعت نتيجه
طلعت
وما تراجعوا على القرار طبقوا القرار
للاسف للاسف
اربعين في المئه من المطاعم اللي كانت
موجوده في المولات اغلقت
باسل وطبعا المطاعم اكثرها افراد افراد
شركات صغيره وكذا سكرت
المولات انهار الاقبال على المولات
هبط بشكل مريب يعني
فالمستثمرين ضرره
مطورين المجمعات التجاريه المولات تضرروا
معهمولات
يفتح في المجمعات التجاريه هذه مطاعم
المستثمرين الصغار خافوا ولا يستثمرون
ما عاد في خلقه فرص
وظائف للسعوديين
فبداء ما تزيد اعداد الموظفين نزلت
الله انقذنا الحمد لله
الرؤيه واقياداتنا وحكمتهم وسياستهم
رجعنا
وزاره الموارد البشريه الجديده بقياده
جديده كان
[موسيقى]
الاجواء كانت مختلفه تماما تفهموا
بس برجع لموضوع بكلمك موضوع التجربه
المولات هذه كيف لما يجي القرار من جهه
واحده تاثير سلبي ولما يكون قرار مشترك
كيف ينجح
عندنا وزاره البشريه مشكورين عدلوا في
القرار التوطين المولات هذا
وجينا
جمعيه قوه جمعيه قوه المطاعم يعني فيها
كلها لان المطاعم مشتركين مع بعض في جمعيه
اسمها جمعيه قوت
مع وزاره البشريه قلنا عشان ما يصير فيها
المفاجات خلونا نحط مع بعض خطه خمسيه
وضعنا خطه خمسيه
مستهدفها توضيع خلق فرص وظيفيه الخمسين
الف شخص خلال خمس سنوات عشره الاف كل سنه
انطبقت فيها 18
الخطه البرنامج السنه الاولى الخطه عشره
الاف
فعليا وظفنا 17 الف سنه سنه اولى والسنه
الثانيه العشره الاف وظفنا 21 الف
والسنه الثالثه 27 الف والسنه الرابعه 32
الف في سنه واحده سنه واحده
الخمسين كم صارت
يمكن
الخامسه فيعني مع السلامه بيكون السنه هذه
السنه الخامسه بتكون حددنا ضعف
فيبينك الفرق بين
لما يكون قرار يجي يملا عليك من طرف واحد
بدون ما ياخذ رايك في الموضوع وبين
الشراكه الفعليه اللي صارت بيننا وبين
البشريه على الخطه الخمسيه هذه وكيف
النتائجها وفي ممهن يمكن بما اننا نتكلم
على قطاع المطاعم انتم رواد في القطاع
واكيد عندكم تجربه تهدونها اليوم في موجه
لمطاعم البرجر والمطاعم بشكل عام بسولف مع
واحد من حقين تطبيقات التوصيل يقول لي
كل المطاعم فيها نزول كل المطاعم من ربع
الاخير للعام الماضي وهالسنه واضح ان
الامور متوجهه الا مطعمين
البيك كوماك
ما تغيرت امورهم ما شاء الله في زود
مش قراءتك اللي صاير في القطاع ليش كثير
قاعد نشوف ناس يفلسون مطاعم تقفل حتى
المطاعم مستمره نتائجها قاعده تراجع وش
التفسير الصراحه انا غير مطلع على
اداه وارقام المطاعم الاخرى ولكن الحمد
لله بفضل رب العالمين صحيح ان الحمد لله
احنا
مبيعاتنا
وفي نمو وحصتنا السوقيه تزداد كل سنه عن
سنه الحمد لله
[موسيقى]
السبب
يعني
والسبب اللي صاير في السوق اجمالا والسبب
انك انت ما تاثرتوا يعني
نازله الانفليشن صحيح وكل القطاعات تاثرت
الاداره
الاداره انك يجب انك تعرف كيف تتعامل
او كيف تدير
[موسيقى]
شركتك بحيث انك تحد من تاثيرات
اقتصاديه اللي صايره ما في شك تضخم القوه
الشرائيه
في انكماش هذه الحقيقه يعني تضخم قاعد
يزيد
التكاليف قاعده ترتفع كلها حقائق هذه
الكل يلمسها لكن كيف اتعامل معها
بحيث انه احد من تاثيرها المالي علي بدون
ما
اخسر حصه سوقيه اعتقد هذا يعني الجواب
مين منافسكم مين منافسه
هل هو البيك ولا هرفي الكل كل منافس ولا
اي مطعم اي مطعم خدمه سريعه منافس بس من
اكثر واحد دائما حاضر في تقاريركم حاضر في
نقاشاتكم كلهم حاضرين للامانه للامانه
يعني يعني
كل اننا ننظر القطاع كامل كل اللاعبين
الكبار في القطاع
نراقبوا ونتابعهم
بدون استثناء ولكن
[ضحك]
بس بس خلي تسمحلي
المنافسين كلهم يعني تربطني تربطني انا
شخصيا فيهم علاقه قويه بجميع بدون استثناء
وكلنا كلنا للامانه يعني ما في احد منهم
الا البعض كل محبه وكل الاحترام والعكس
يعني ننظر ننظر لبعض على
المنافسه صحيه لنا جميعا
فيعني
انا ما اتدمر من نجاح ولا هم يتدمرون من
نجاحي العكس يعني
كلنا قاعدين
نرتقي بالقطاع كلنا قاعدين نخلق سوق
كلنا قاعدين ناخذ حصتنا من السوق هذه فهذا
الحقيقه الروحي موجوده بيننا بين كل
منافسين يعني بدون استثناء وهذه هل لكم
بما ان موضوعنا انتوا كرواد قاده في
هالقطاع هل لكم اي دور للمجتمع في ناحيه
اصحاب المطاعم خل نقول يعني اليوم في كميه
شباب دخلوا في مجال برجر مهوله وازعم انه
جلهم خسروا واطلعوا صحيح ايش دوركم
لتمكينهم لتقويتهم لدعمهم هل في شيء ممتاز
ممتاز طال عمرك طبعا انا من مؤسسين جمعيه
مطاعم المؤسسينها وانا شخصيا رئيس مجلس
اداره الجمعيه واحد اهم اهداف الجمعيه هو
دعم صغار المستثمرين دعم صغار مستثمرين
دعمهم طال عمرك في البرامج التدريبيه في
المعرفه في الفرانشايزنج في كل هالجوانب
ونشاركهم بتجاربنا كقطاع يعني مسوي يعني
دامجين تجربه مقداومز مع تجربه البيك مع
تجربه
تجاربنا في برامج التدريبيه وبرامج
تعريفيه لهم وعندنا اكاديميه اكاديميه قوه
هذه يعني
مستهدفه الشريحه هذه فالعكس يعني هذه من
الاشياء اللي انا شخصيا فخور فيها انما
اكتشفت تجربه القطاع باكمله بشكل اكبر من
لوكات تجربه مقدار من الاشياء اللي يعني
في تركيز عليها كبير اليوم موضوع المحتوى
المحلي احنا سولفنا شوي حدود 55% لكن متى
نبدا نشوف اهم مكوناتكم اللحم والدجاج
والبطاطس تاخذونا من السوق السعودي
زي ما تفضلت عند 55% اليو حاليا الان
شغالين على الدجاج
وقطع كبير فيه نهايه السنه هذه ان شاء
الله بيكون الدجاج وموطن
فهذا بيرفع نسبتنا بشكل كبير من 55%
بنرتفع لها حوالي 70% مع الدجاج الحاله
يبقى
المنتجين الرئيس اللحم اللحم
والبطاطس اللحم موجود في الخطه
وهذا بيرجعني الى برنامج التحول الوطني
والرؤيه
انا
شخصيا من 30 سنه اترجى الشركات العالميه
تعالوا افتحوا عندنا في السعوديه استثمروا
في السعوديه
وكان دائما جواب لا لا
صعوبه صعوبه حصول على التاشيرات
تعرفي ذيك الايام كان الواحد لو يبغى يزور
السعوديه كان يعني
[ضحك]
رقم اثنين
الانظمه القضائيه لا تحميهم حقوقهم
تشريعات
فيها ضبابيه
يعني مستحيل
انا طبعا تغير الان بداوا يجون وبداوا
يستثمرون
قبل شهر تقريبا
احد اكبر المصانع اللحوم العالميه
اعلنوا
انهم بيستثمرون هنا في السعوديه وهم من
موردين مقداد فتواصلنا معهم والان انا
وياهم بتنسيق على الاستثمارهم يكون في خط
انتاج بحيث ان الحمله تكون مصنع محليا فهي
ايضا في الخطه هذه في الخطه طبعا يبقى
البطاطس البطاطس البطاطس يا طويل العمر
في السعوديه ما هي من
الزراعه الرئيسيه عندنا الكميه اللي
نستهلكها كميه مهوله تفوق بمراحل انتاج
السوق نوعيه البطاطس نستخدمها
تحتاج الى طقس معين عشان كذا ما تزرع الا
في
منطقه
شمال غرب امريكا
بسبب الامطار وكذا
من صعب من صعب
الدجاج واللحم يعني
كنت اسولف مع مجموعه من الاصدقاء
واسالهم مش يهمكم تعرفون الحلقه فجتني
مجموعه تساؤلات صراحه واحده منها يقول
يعني يبدو يبدو اليوم انتم عندكم اكبر حصه
او من اكبر حصص السوقيه في قطاع المطاعم
ومع ذلك انتم من اكبر المنفقين في التسويق
صحيح اذا انتو حاضرين وش تبون
النبي طال عمرك نحافظ على حصتنا
[موسيقى]
فهدفنا دائما
نزيد حصتنا السوقيه وفي تحديده في كاس
العالم ما دخلته باسم ماك دخلته
شو اسمه
التسويق لخدمه التوصيل التسويق لخدمه
التوصيل لان خدمه توصيل يا طويل العمر
جديده على كثير من الاسواق انه في
السعوديه ما هي جديده اطلقناهم قبل 20 سنه
لكن عالميا عالميا
امريكا واوروبا وكذا حديثي تجربه حديثه
بالنسبه لهم لهم اربع خمس سنوات تقريبا
فما زال في مرحله التوعيه التوعيه
ودعايات اللي مكناس في كاس العالم هذه من
قبل شكل مكناس العالميه ما هي من عندنا
فعشان كذا هم مركزين على رافع نسبه
التوعيه لخدمه التوصيل الطلبات عالميا هل
صار في حديث على الدمج بين الشركتين اللي
في السعوديه الغربيه والجنوبيه لا ما في
حديث ولا في خطوه للدمج ولكن نعتبر انفسنا
نعتبر انفسنا يعني شركه واحده موحدين في
التسعين موحدين في كل شيء في امور حملات
تسويقيه تسعير منتجات كل يعني الموارد
البشريه نشتغل انا وياهم يعني يد بيد بشكل
يومي وعلاقتنا جدا ممتازه مع بعض
واهدافنا واحده وخططنا وحده في في سؤال
ابو مهاب توسع صدرك
من اوسع ما يكون تسلم
عجزت القى احد مقتنع بسالفه حلال ما حد
مقتنع مهما تحاولون تقنعون او خوفتونا لما
تقولون حلال ترى المنتجاتنا حلال في
السعوديه والله ما عمري فكرت فيها الا يوم
سويتوها سالت اللي حولي
انسان واحد يقول لي هل الحمله ناجحه او
فادتني او ازدادت شكوكي ما في الاثر عكسي
ممتاز هل جاهزين تعترفون انه ما كانت
موفقه ولا عندك ثانيه انا مصر انها موفقه
كيف
يا طويل العمر سياساتنا اللي يقودنا اللي
يقودنا
المستهلك
كل شي نسويه
نتيجه
للمرئيات ومقترحات والاستفسارات اللي
تجينا من المستهلكين
اليوم اكبر عندنا منصه عندنا منصه اسمها
من حقك انت تعرف
المنصه هذه طال عمرك ما ادري زرتها ولا لا
ما زرتها اتمنى انك تزورها تشوف تطلع
عليها
من سنين اخذناها من مبدا الشفافيه اسال اي
سؤال ونجاوبك عليه بكل شفافيه اسال اي
سؤال ونجاوب بس كذا جميع الاسئله موجوده
في موقع فتشوف سؤال من احمد سؤال عبد الله
وسؤال كذا وتشوف الاجواء موجوده
اكثر استفسار يجينا اليوم على المنصه هل
نحوكم حلا اجيب
هذا حقيقه
منصه السعوديه
انا شخصيا انا مستاء منها الموضوع
لان معروفه اصلا ما في شيء في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
انا اعرف الشيء هذا مو تعرف الشيء هذا
وانا افترض ان الكل عفشي هذا
ولكن الواقع الناس قاعد تسال هل منتجاتكم
حلال هل سؤال رقم واحد عندنا هل
المنتجاتكم حلال
فمن هذا المنطلق مجبرين اننا نسوي الحملات
هذه لان من الواضح ان في ناس قاعده تشكك
في المنتجاتنا حلال ولا لا
ليش مشككين الله والعالم يمكن يرجع لموضوع
العلامه التجاريه ومقدونس
لكن
في سؤال هنا على موضوع الطرح في السوق انت
قلت ان هذا من محظور
في في كان تغريده لاحمد الزيني في عام
2015 يقول
انا تدخل
لمجال الكاجوال او او مطاعم الكاجوال ما
هو
هل في اي توجهون في هالمجالات ابدا ابدا
في السعوديه
تحصلنا من ندخل في
الامتداد لنفس المطعم نفسه انه يصير مكناس
بيطور
خط كاجوال ما في انتم الحين قاعدين اكثر
في موضوع القهوه والفطور هذه هي القاب عند
مكه فيه صحيح وهذه صارت حتى تتعمدون انكم
انتم في بعض او مو انتم في السعوديه بس
عالميا يبون ينجحونها بانه يحطونها هي
الدور الارضي هي اللي في الواجهه صحيح
ويذبون الفرع فوق صحيح
جميل جميل
طال عمرك تعتبر يعني تجربه حديثه
ماكدونالدز عالميا نسبيا
[موسيقى]
ونجحت في كثير من الاسواق بحيث اني اصبحت
هي العلامه الاولى في تلك الاصوات منها
منها
استراليا
كندا
وفي عندها اسواق اخرى يعني ما كافيه دخلت
السوق
وبشده بحيث انها اصبحت هي العلامه رقم
الاولى
عندنا طبعا في السعوديه دخلنا مؤخرا بدينا
قبل سنتين في فتحنا اول اول او قبضتها
سنوات اول اول فرع اليوم عندنا اكثر من
150 فرع مكه في خلال ثلاث سنوات الجايه
الماضي عفوا
والسنه هذه مع نهايه السنه هذه بتكون
متوفره في جميع فروعنا بدون استخدام
وعندنا طموحه
ما كافيه يتبع نفس معايير
ومبادئ مقدارسه
افضل جوده
سرعه
بقلع الاسعار يعني هذا الحقيقه اللي وش
يميز مكه فيه عن البقيه
هذا الثلاثه
ولو بختم ابو مها بسؤال واقول لك انت قسمت
الثلاثين سنه الماضيه كل عشر سنوات لها
ثيم
فالعشر سنوات القادمه ايش الثيم حقه وين
تبي توصلون وين نبي نوصل
حصنا اننا نبقى في مرحله الولاء هذه
ما بعدها مرحله
[موسيقى]
الولاء زياده حصتنا السوقيه
زياده توسعنا اليوم عنده طال عمرك زي ما
قلت لك
ان شاء الله مع نهايه
منها 400 في منطقتنا و200 في منطقه
الغربيه موضوع الجامعه
ضمن العشرات الجايه
اليوم طال عمرك بدات
ممتاز يا طويل العمر المركز تدريب عندنا
عندنا مركز تدريب طبعا من من اول يوم
فتحنا السيستم مركز تدريب خاص الموظفين
مركز تدريب خاصه موظفين نام
نقدم برامج تدريبيه للجميع الموظفين من
طاقم خدمه الى رئيس الشركه
ودورات مستمره
[موسيقى]
كانت هي
مركز تدريب
[موسيقى]
عندهم جامعه مكداوس
اسمها
الجامعه هذه جامعه معتمده رسميه معتمده
وتقدم شهاده بكالوريوس
جامعه مقداس لها ثمان فروع في العالم فقط
موجوده في مئه دوله من هالميه دوله في
ثمانيه دول اللي فيها جامع
ابشرك الحمد لله
الرياض اعتمدت
الجامعه التاسعه على مستوى العالم
ان شاء الله قبل هاي السنه تخرج هذه ما
يقدر يدخل فيها موظفينا موظفين فقط موظفين
وهذه
يعني
تختم فروعكم انتم فقط ما لها علاقه
في المنطقه كلها يرسلون موظفين حتى تخرج
السعوديه
يرسلون يرسلون موظفينهم
لمركز جامعتنا لتلقي الدورات عشان في
دورات ما تعطى الا في المراكز الجامعه
المعتمده وهذه بس
معهد المنصه سعوديه منصه اجيالنا نركز
فيها على ثلاث محاور رئيسيه
التثقيف الصحي
عن منتجاتنا وعن الشفافيه
وتحسين جوده منتجاتنا تحسين هذه من
الاشياء اللي يعني نشتغل عليها باستمرار
باستمرار نعمل على تحسين جوده منتجاتنا
ازاله المواد الحافظه ازاله ملونات ازاله
تخفيض نسب الاملاح
الصوديوم الى اخره
عندك يا طويل العمر
الجانب الانساني
الاعمال الانسانيه مركزين فيها بشكل كبير
على فئه اطفال متلازمه الداون
خلال خمس سنوات الماضيه طبعا سوي خلال سنه
حملات مستمره
للتبرع للجمعيات هذه
خلال خمس سنوات الماضيه تبرعنا باكثر من
عشره مليون ريال لصالح الفئه هذه من خلال
ثلاث جمعيات جمعيات
صوت وديسكا
[موسيقى]
دعم مستمر للبرنامج هذه توظيف توظيف ممتاز
مادام عندنا اليوم اكثر من 60
شاب يشتغلون معنا في مطاعمنا وعندنا خطه
اننا نوصل الى اكثر من 200 خلال سنتين
الجايه ان شاء الله
الجانب الثالث التوطين
التوطين زي ما قلت لك يعني
فخورين في ريادتنا المجال في مجال توطين
وظائف
وحريصين على اننا نشرك
قطاع الخاص ونشرك العامه بتجربتنا
ونجاحاتنا والى اخره
هذه
ركائز البرامج اللي مركزين عليها جميل
عارفين قلت لك هذا كان اخر سؤال لكن بسؤال
يعني احنا دائما في سقراط مركز على
قصه التحول اللي قاعدين نعيشها وناخذها من
عده زوايا ومن زاويتكم كانت تجربه القطاع
الخاص وتفاعلوا مع القطاع الحكومي لو بطلب
منك وهذا يكون ختام حلقتنا
ابرز تغير
لمسته مع قصه او مثال يقدر يثبت او يوثق
هذا التغير اللي انتو عشتوه كمستثمرين مع
الجهات حكوميه جميل جميل عندي يا طويل
العمر اذا تسمح لي ابشركك
بقصتين خير وبركه يعني صارت تبين لك الفرق
ما قبل وبعد
القصه الاولى يا طويل العمر
نظام
التسمم الغذائي
هبه عنده وزاره الشؤون البلديه والامانات
على تسكير المطاعم
لحالات اشتباب تسمم
فجاه في نظام في نظام في الوزاره للتسمم
الغذائي ولكن كان نظام منسي الخمسين سنه
بعدين قرر في ذاك الوقت انهم يفعلون نظام
وصار فيه مداهمات مداهمات على مطاعم
واغلاق النظام النظام يقول اذا صار فيه
نظام القديم كان يقول اذا في اجتماع حاله
تسمم تغلق المنشاه لمده سبع ايام واذا ثبت
تسمم تغلق لمده 30 يوم ومع اغراضه
فالنظام تغلق سبع ايام تقطع رزقي سبعه
ايام على اشتباه حط خط تحت كلمه اشتباه
اي احد يرفع السماعه كلم البلديه ويقول
انا والله رحت اليوم للمقدارلز وتغديت
وجاني يتسموا
ما تدري الا مداهمين المطعم
دوريه بسيارات البلديه والى اخره قفلوا
المطعم بالسلاسل ويحطون عليها مئه ستيكر
تم اغلاق المطعم بسبب تسمم
انت مار من عند المطعم بتشوفها الضجه
وبتشوف الاستيكرات وش بتصير ما عندهم
مدى الحياه صح ولا لا راحت الشركه
وصاروا بعد والاسوا
يروجون هالحملات على الوسائل الاعلام
نتواصل اجتماعي تم اليوم اغلاق 270 مطعم
ويحطون
فاعدمتنا اعدمتنا
وكل الحالات اللي صارت كات اشتباه سبع
ايام بعدين بعد ما تخلص سبع ايام يقول كيف
يفتح مطعمك
وبعد ما تطلع نتائج التحاليل بعد ثلاث
شهور اربع شهور خمس شهور تطلع تطلع عندها
تحاليل نتايجكم سليمه كم مقفل لكم المطعم
عشرات عشرات عشرات كم منها صار فعلا في
حاله تسمم ولا حاله ولا مطعم
ولا مطعم
وهذا كنت اقوله لو الله لا يقدر الله لا
يقدر
لو صار عندي حاله تسمم الله لا يقدر
الضحيه ما حيكون واحد ولا اثنين يكونون كل
اللي فرع ذاك اليوم مئات الاف بيصير
فبتصير تم حالات تسمم جماعيه
من شبه مستحيل عندك حاله تسمم فرديه والله
الفرع زارة ألف بس واحد يتسمم او اثنين
يتسمموا مستحيل
طلبت اللقاء مع الوزير البلديه كان
الدكتور محمد ال الشيخ الله يذكره بالخير
قابلته
وتفهم تفهم تفهم المنطق وتفهم
وكمطقي انا اذا ثبت تسمم
تسكن شهر اغلبني بالكامل لو تبي
بس لا لا تشوه سمعتي
وتقطع رزقي على اشتباه
هي كانت مشكله في كلمه اشتباه
واشتباها من شخص واحد الشخص واحد يكفي
شخص مغرب شخص زعلان شيء يمكن شخص راح وزعل
من موظف ولا زعل من تجربه ولا زعل ايش
يرفع سماعه يتهمني بالتسمم يجون يقفلون
اسبوع
تفهم وقال
نادى الوكيل المهني وقال كذا كذا كذا
موضوع وانا اتفق مع النظام يجي باعاده
السياق بحيث انه ما يكون مجحف لقطاع الخاص
انا مستبشر بالخير خلاص
تواصلت مع الوكيل رتبنا يوم ورشه عمل
دعينا الاسامي
المعروفه في السوق قعدنا طعم فرشه عمل
دخل وكيل
صور معنا
وطلع
بس بس دخلوا طلب ما
حضر اللي تحته مسؤول عن تسمم او شيء قسم
التسمم كذا حظر مع الورشه حكينا حكينا
حكينا حكينا
ما اقترب ولا كلمه من اللي قلناه
خلص خلصنا جاب المحضر ومجهز المحضر
قال هذا المحضر النهائي
ولا صار في اي تعديل
هذا قبل الرؤيه بعد الرؤيه
رجعنا فتحنا موضوع مره ثانيه مع
نفس الوزاره
مع الوزير البلديه
امر
اوجه بتشكيل لجنه مشتركه بين وزاره وبين
القطاع الخاص
اللجنه طلبوا مننا قالوا
انتم اعطونا مقترحاتكم
ونبغى مقترحاتكم تكون مبنيه على تجارب
عالميه
فاخذنا اربع دول اخذنا طعمك
خلنا امريكا بريطانيا اخذنا كندا واخذنا
الدوله الرابعه الامارات اظن اخذنا اربع
دول متقدمه جبنا انظمه التسمم الغذائي
على مدى اشهر قعدنا مع بعض اصغنا النظام
الجديد
وطبق النظام
طبق فشركه في الفرق هذا مثال المثال
الثاني طال عمرك الاربعه
في التسعينات كان مسموح 24 ساعه
كنا نفتح 24 ساعه بعد فروع وكانت
تمثل نسبه كبيره من المبيعات يعني فوق
خمسه الى عشره من المبيعات تجي فالفتره
عندك ناس يشتغلون في ورديات ليليه الى
اخره فيه في في طلب
بعدين جاء قرار منع 24 ساعه
المطاعم انها تشتغل لان الساعه 2:00 صباحا
فتفتح بعد الفجر تسكر
وتفتح بعد الفجر
كانها لا حول ولا قوه الا بالله
يعني حاولنا نسوق ل 4 ساعه معك في اي تقبل
بعدين جت الطامه الكبرى لما سمعنا وبدايه
يكتبون في الوسائل الاعلام
صار في دراسه انهم يسكرون تسع المساء
يجبروننا الاغلاق الساعه تسعه المساء
70% من مبيعات القطاع تجي من بعد صلاه
العشاء
بحكم طبيعه اجوائنا الناس ما تطلع
في النهار الا للضروره كل الناس يطلعون
يتمشون فتره 70% فانت بتجي بتسكر الساعه
تسعه المساء بتقتل قطاع الاقتصاد كله مو
بس المطاعم يعني كلمه الانشطه
رحنا وتكلمنا وحاولنا يعني حاولنا نهديهم
ما كان فيه كانوا معزمين ماشيين ماشيين في
مسار
وكان يعطون مبررات
ولكن يعني مالها يعني القطاع الخاص
والاقتصاد كان
اخر همهم اولويات اخرى يعني ما لها اي
علاقه في القطاع
بعد الرؤيه و برنامج تحول
رحت
قابلت معالي وزير التجاره دكتور القصبي
وقلت له
سويت له دراسه سويت دراسه وقدمتها له
فوائد
24 ساعه على
الدوله ميزانيه الدوله
والمجتمع على التوظيف كم فرصه وظيفيه
بتخلق
فوائدها المجتمع وهكذا
خلال 24 ساعه طلع قرار بسماح بال 24 ساعه
مجددا
مجددا اللي كان موجود سابقا الغي الغي وقف
لمده 15 سنه ولا عشرين سنه في 24 ساعه
اسمحوا في
فتح مطاعم اربع ساعات في اخر خدمه للمجتمع
يا اخي عندك اطباء عندك طلبه عندك رجال
امن عندك
كان ما كان في شيء مفتوح
فيها
منفعه لقطاع خاص في منفعل التوطين توظيف
فيها منفعه للدوله
ياخذ الرسوم علينا اربع ساعات خضر ربع
ساعه وادفع رسوم عليها خير وبركه
وهذا تقدر تلخص فيها
الاختلاف اللي تلاحظون
لك يعني
[موسيقى]
انا انا شخصيا او انظر ان يعني مع
حكمه وتوجه قيادتنا نعيش في عصر اقتصادي
جديد لم يسبق له مثيل في تاريخ المملكه
العربيه السعوديه منذ تاسيسها الى اليوم
وهذه بدايتها
يعني
مليء بالتفاؤل على المستقبل ان شاء الله
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
واللي ياكدها طال عمرك
يعني ثقه القطاع الخاص في الحكومه
ما قد مر علي ثقابه بهذا المستوى
مرت علينا سنين طويله
كانوا التجار يستثمرون اموالهم خارج
المملكه
او جزء من اموالهم خارج المملكه الان
اللي انا اشوفه واللي اعرفه سواء كان من
طرفنا ولا من طرف
يعني معارفنا رجال الاعمال كذا صار العكس
الان
بسبب الثقه اللي موجوده بسبب التفاؤل
الموجود بسبب الفرص اللي موجوده ما عاد
احد يفكر انه يستثمر
[موسيقى]
خارج هذا افضل مكان للاستثمار
ليس بس للسعوديين
لكل العالم
وهذا حتى اللي يسمع من رجال الاعمال
الاجانب الان صاير فيه كل العيون صارت على
السعوديه
يبحث عن فرصه الاستثماريه في السعوديه وكل
الله رغبه انه يستثمر في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه
ويعني الحوار ما اقدر اقول الا شكرا على
قبول الدعوه موفقين في الوصول ل600 فرع ان
شاء الله
وما يصاحبها من زياده توطين ومحتوى محلي
شكرا ابوها على قبول الدعوه شكرا لك يا
ابو عبد الرحمن على استضافه وسعيد جدا
واتمنى التوفيق شكرا لكم شكرا فهد القصير
في اعداد وانتاج الحلقه ياسر الغانم وعبد
الرحمن عطاس وياسر كدشه خلف الكاميرات في
تسجيل الصوت يوسف ابراهيم وفي التحرير
محمد الديني وفندق الصوتيه محمد الحسن وفي
الاشراف على الانتاج رزانه هيثم هذا
بودكاست سقراط احد منتجات شركه ثمانيه
للنشر والتوزيع
[موسيقى]